we were talking backstage against your
wishes and we were just chatting and I'm
a history buff when we were chatting
about American history and we did find
it a little bit of a note of optimism
which I wanted to hit on as we closed
which is it was this feeling that both
you and I were talking about I think I
brought up that that this notion that
people get so panicked and terrified
about this person who's our half or
maybe a little more than half the
country about the person we have as
president now and I was bringing up this
idea that we've survived many flawed
people in office and our government is
built very well and institutions are
very strong there's a lot of scary stuff
happening right now but I felt a little
bit optimistic and you were echoing that
sentiment a little bit yeah and and I
meant it I'm optimistic there's lots of
concerning things going on today we
should all not get numb and make sure
we're holding our leaders accountable to
telling the truth and not undermining
the rule of law but we're gonna be okay
the culture of America is so deep and so
strong we were talking about de
Tocqueville saw it in the 1800's we are
the same kind of people we care about
things that unite us no matter what our
political affiliation is so we're gonna
be fine that doesn't mean we shouldn't
pay attention yep but I just want people
know we're gonna be okay this is an
amazing country and we fight about all
kinds of things important issues but we
have in common a commitment to a set of
values and that's who we are and we're
gonna be okay
[Applause]
you